[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mute everything okay you guys should be
able to hear us fine man
okay speak real quick
yo yo okay they can hear that's fine
just to make sure
that none of you people saying we late
is five o'clock now it's 501
but we clicked that button before it was
five o'clock so that shows you right
there that we on time
and that that's just keep you guys
keeping you guys honest man you know we
got to keep we got to keep the chat on
and sometimes you guys a little extra
sometimes you guys are a little extra
and i love people are already commenting
on the background of of your
is that what the background was for for
your podcast
no i i know that that was that's that
that's new like 10 minutes ago knew
yes son
what's funny someone said uh attic
cleaned his room what's funny is like
over here is just a bunch of laundry
that i got sitting here that i'm about
to uh do and uh it's laundry day so my
blankets are stuffer in the in the
laundry uh
my room generally looks like this it's
just there'll be stuff on my bed that
would be like
sometimes my girlfriend's laying in my
bed so i like i don't want to invade her
privacy to that point but addicts here
alone today
i can do whatever the hell he wants
ain't nobody gonna stop
attic from doing what he want to do so
what's going to you guys lord addict
here i got i got dirt griggity i have no
clue where big cloud is he is missing in
action does not surprise me one bit i'm
sure he'll pop in here sooner or later
uh welcome to the attic show where we
talk about the past
present and future game what's going on
dirk
nothing much man some um you know
i was thinking this might be a slow day
you know there's not a lot of news
and then
boom
boom you know this activism blizzard
playstation xbox this this whole thing
man this has been in the news for like
going on like the whole month of august
there was plenty of talk about this
activision blizzard uh deal and
playstation they're kind of upset about
certain things and bro as soon as it
calms down it cools off
something else pops up
i love it this is great this is great
content for
guys like us
yeah and and if you guys think whatever
we do on the show
it ain't gonna be a fraction of what
king does sunday at one piece
you know it bro
oh man
you know what fame man i see i see you
doing those shorts on youtube hey yo
those shorts out of there
you got to put those on tick tock too i
don't know if they are on tickets i
think they are on tick tock yeah but
they're funny bro i got to follow you on
tick tock this stuff is hilarious yeah i
don't really do like my tic toc my
girlfriend be saying my tick tock
thing be weird because like it's not
like your typical dude like thirst traps
and stuff i'd be having like educational
videos trolling videos like that
obviously
the occasional thirst trap throws up
itself online but it don't really happen
that often minds is 100 percent thirst
traps
i just watched girls shaking their butt
all day and you know some sports stuff
obviously and some video game stuff
that's it that's my
comedy if i see sports stuff pop up on
my timeline i'm clicking that little
icon says i don't want to see nothing
like this never again
so i appreciate you guys for coming
through man we're going to talk about a
good amount today man we got a good
little show going on
obviously we're going to talk about that
that call of duty dell that just dropped
it's fresh off the press we're going to
talk about that i love that word i love
that phrase fresh off the press
and then and then we got cd projekt red
i kind of want to talk a little bit
about cd projekt red where it looks like
they are uh you know coming around the
corner when it comes to the cyberpunk
scenario then the ubisoft showcase get a
little bit of predictions see what's
going on over there man i'm sure there's
gonna be a lot of stuff that uh
apparently it's gonna be assassin's
creed focused a little bit
and then there's there's a playstation
update
um you know
playstation
they
did this
update which is literally just giving
you stuff that the xbox has had for
years and people want to like
like
it's like being patted on the back
for doing something that you were
supposed to do years ago it's like the
equivalent of like if my job before i
was let go of my job
if they're like we're gonna start giving
you good health insurance you should
have been doing it what you're talking
about
and then we're gonna talk about
playstation being caught red-handed what
they handed the cookie jar
and apparently this new design for
playstation 5 is making it cheaper and
they still raising that price everywhere
else but america
so
obviously you know let's let's get
straight into the intros real quick dirt
what you've been playing here lately man
what what's that game that's been
getting
you excited
honestly bro i just finished saints roll
it was okay it was okay it was the same
it was it's a saints row game you know
corny dialogue
average graphics but fun you know
there's a lot of fun to be had there um
yeah i just finished it there's still a
whole lot of stuff for me to do if i
want
i think i'm at the primary uninstall it
but
i thought i would give it a solid seven
you know if you like the franchise
you'll definitely like this one
um but that's that's really about it um
i'm thinking about going back to my ps5
and cutting it on well you know what
maybe not because 2k about to come out
and i'm a big 2k guy so
yeah but stage roads been been the game
i've been putting my focus on lately is
it sad that when my brother is like can
i borrow your playstation 5 to play the
last of us for the eighth time in a row
i keep i forget i have it
i'm like oh it is over there yeah i
don't care man i don't care she thought
about buying the last of us re-bleached
as my boy sean called it did you see
what angry joe did
yes he re-uploaded
he re-uploaded his uh his review
from 2014 of the 2014 one and then he
shows him putting filters on the actual
video and then he names it the
remastered review
i'm sorry i'm thinking that's hilarious
that that that is hilarious that is
awesome
yeah so it's just like you know there's
a lot been going on man this is
this is awesome because we was there for
what a good two months dirt where we was
winging it every week yeah like yes
every week we was coming in here with
zero to talk about and somehow made it
work somehow every week me we made it
work that's how you know when we know
what we doing we come in here with zero
to talk about make it last two hours i
don't know how we did it and to this day
i couldn't tell you how we did it but we
did it it just happened it just happened
so you know what i think the first thing
you know
let's just let's let's talk about it man
let's let's talk about
the playstation call of duty and xbox
still so have you are you completely up
to date with this uh what jim ryan said
and everything um
for the most part i i didn't get a
chance to read the full article but i've
been reading some highlights i've been
looking at some of the things the people
saying hey you know what surprises me
there's a lot of people talking trash
that usually don't talk trash about this
kind of stuff man
you know i saw the homie ran kind of
throw some shots uh saw
ryan mccaffrey gotta throw some shots
and i'm like whoa
this is crazy these guys are talking
some trash so um you know i've seen a
couple things here and there
yeah
so pretty much for those of you that
hasn't been keeping up to date i know
some of you probably aren't on twitter
like that if you're on definitely go
follow us on twitter you know my
twitter's lord addiction what's your
twitter dirt
griggity
i g-g-i-t-y yeah i'm close to 4 000
followers man go down there and follow
me man let's get me to 4 000 followers
so all right so two dollar subscribe
from flame i really want this still to
happen so it hurts playstation okay okay
okay the messiness has officially
started let me go out there and say that
now
so
pretty much what's happened is is jim
ryan's kind of being a little salty just
a little bit
dance move ryan's like look you know he
ain't feeling the deal that they made
with the call of duty thing and
apparently
it only lasts three years after
the initial agreement that they got
going for with uh activision currently
uh for those of you that know that that
that ends at the end of next year
so
what's funny is they really only got
four years of call of duty labs like
let's just be real here if you if you
play in call of duty and you're a huge
thing you know you're the jabaris the
personas and that's like that's your
bread
and your butter
you're gonna have to come over here xbox
to be able to play that man let's just
be honest here man i know people are
upset i don't think that the quality of
call of duty is going to go down but i
will say
is this going to be on xbox only
so what what
regardless what it is like i don't know
if you know they might use
they might use that as a
a bargaining chip
closer to those that three-year deals up
to be able to like look like i wouldn't
be surprised if microsoft's like
if we give you call of duty you giving
us everything like no more final
fantasies exclusives like you are
dropping your guns
and i'm i'mma arm you like we gonna do
what america did in japan after the
world war two like you can't
what's funny is to my knowledge japan
can't they don't have the right to bear
arms they can't assemble that's what it
is i can't it's someone army that's
that's literally what phil about popping
in he'd be like oh right you want call
of duty where you got to drop every gun
you have like you know drop them all
we're gonna pick them up we're gonna put
them in our thing those are our guns now
you
can sit in your [ __ ] you can sit in
in your house and make some money every
month but as far as shooting us we
taking all that ammo back i know that's
absolutely i know that's being like
legit like crazy and that is what it is
i just when i read this man i was like
yo
because if if jim ryan's coming out and
saying a statement like that there's
something going on why he felt the need
to talk about it like that yeah so what
is your opinion dirk well you know first
off before i give my take on i actually
have the exact quote if you want me to
read it if you don't mind yeah yeah yeah
let's read it i hadn't intended to
comment on what i understood to be a
private business discussion but i feel
the need to set the record straight
because phil spencer brought this into
the public forum now first of all he
said yo feel put the business out there
so i'm going to respond to it that's not
this is jim ryan speaking
then he said microsoft has only offered
for call of duty to remain on
playstation for three years after the
current agreement between activision and
sony ends
after almost 20 years of call of duty on
playstation their proposal was
inadequate on many levels and failed to
take account of the impact of on our
gamers we want to guarantee playstation
gamers continue to have the highest
quality call of duty experience and
microsoft proposal undermines this
principle
uh all i'm saying man
is phil
if you're
if if your plan is to walk in the club
acting non-threatening but you actually
gonna shoot the place up do it man like
dude cause here's the thing you took my
final fantasy away from me doesn't look
like i i had i'm still waiting for
persona it's finally coming but i'm
still waiting for it you know all these
other things that's gone off the
platform i have zero sympathy for anyone
complaining about this let me get this
two dollar superchat real quick uh from
lebron98
jim lyon has been promoted to jim wyan
and then we got a member chat from uh
pixelbit g jim is lying before phil
commented sony released a please keep
the deal that uh the day it happened uh
cfd screw him no uh sot what does he
mean by sot i don't know [ __ ] out of
luck no that's not it no i screw them
cut them off light them up on fire i
agree with you that i think that's the
reason that i'm a little bit more i want
to see the world burn because no one
cared about when i couldn't play certain
games that i wanted to play what's funny
is people you got a lot of people that
don't play final fantasy or jrpgs in
general or anything in that kind of
genre and when
when sony walks on the stage and throws
out these these these monies to to keep
it off the platform you guys say well
you know you guys just got to go buy it
on on playstation you got to buy a
playstation but when microsoft comes up
and buys the building
then that's an issue and i feel like
that mentality is dumb
it's like look like
you guys all last generation
i'm not talking about anyone specific
you guys all last generation was
constantly saying
sony
spend your money microsoft spends your
money microsoft bought all this money i
remember so many vehicles of so many
videos and so many twitters
tweeting saying
microsoft has all this money and they do
nothing with the but when microsoft
comes on me like it's like it's like
phil spencer woke up one day and he got
petty and he looked at someone tweet
that said
hold my beard like
like it's it's crazy hold up um slow but
final fantasy remake isn't enough think
about how much money call of duty
generates there's no promising to stop
jacking third-party exclusives that will
keep from eventually making cod
exclusive i i
if you want uh slow-mo you could pop in
here if you want if i don't know what is
this man yeah i don't know if you're
busy here's my thing the reason i say
that call of duty would be enough to
stop all that if microsoft literally
walked in there and put their dick on
the table and said we ain't doing
nothing
with call of duty it's ours
but
if you want to stop doing the size sus
stuff
you know maybe we will let that game be
on that platform
i think microsoft sony probably makes
more money off call of duty than they do
off all those games combined
all of them combined because they they
still have a partnership score enix is
still getting a paycheck they're still
taking cuts of it
they're still getting a lot of that
money regardless if they play royalties
there's a lot of things that goes into
that and
not to mention call of duty sells
probably more than all those combined
every year
we got a lucious augustus with a 13
month
uh no one paying attention to tencent
microsoft looking around like y'all
checking me but
but they bringing guns in the club tents
and buying everyone uh we'll maybe we
can we can get to that man we can get to
that
so what is what is what is your take on
this dirt do you think that do you think
that they actually got to pull
call of duty off the playstation
platform
um
i think
this generation they'll you know what
you guys can keep call of duty this
generation
but next generation whenever that is
seven eight years from now
they might make it exclusive i mean
obviously we don't know we're just
speculating here but that's what it
seems like to me
and
i always say this business is business i
had no problem with with playstation had
uh uh
like things in the contract that said
games cannot go to game pass i had no
problem with that because this is
business it's business and in business
you have to be aggressive right when
xbox
crap the bed at the beginning of xbox
one generation playstation took
advantage of that
they say hey
you can't play use games on their
console you can play on rs though here's
how
this is how you trade games and look as
a xbox fan i remember watching that like
oh my god for a video for a video that
probably took them five minutes to
record
it was five minutes
it was devastating devastating but
that's business bro
that so you can't just be like uh you
know what i'm going to let my biggest
competitor here come on guys
that's like
i always say right i never have the
heart to to really sell drugs right
because now this is crazy analogy but
bear with me because
i'm the type of guy i tell the crackhead
you know what bring the money back next
week right you know
then like they're going to take
advantage of me and then my biggest
competitor is going to take advantage of
that
they're going gonna take it well he's
weak he's this he don't know what to do
business is business you have to be
aggressive you can't be soft
right bill spencer and xbox they know
what they have to do they're microsoft
they're one of the most successful
businesses in the world
they didn't get get that way from being
soft
worrying about the other competitors oh
you know what uh we want to give we want
to help apple out back when well
well actually i think they did help out
apple back in the days but now apple is
a monster i guarantee it like like they
wish they probably didn't help alcohol
back in the day because they're absolute
monster now so actually
on stalking
well that's one thing but the thing is
they're going to leave it on there
but if it's if it goes
just the extra three years bro
it is what it is and it's clear that
this is really hurting playstation like
i mentioned we've been talking about
this third time they've they've talked
about it like publicly we've been
talking about this
for a month
um and that's that's his business man i
believe if playstation had the capital
to do this they would have done it
themselves trust me they would have
and part of me feels like
they're on the horizon to picking up
square enix
so it's just like
if you eat like i don't know if they're
talking to them i don't know if they've
already bought them they're just waiting
for a good time to announce it
or or anything related to that but
if you're even remotely talking to them
about buying that company you're a
hypocrite sony why because you because
when you buy stuff you have no thought
process on where that pla where those
games are going to be on what platform
those games could be on you know the
answer
so how are you going to go on twitter
and cry and scream cry me a river i
don't know who who sung that song but
it's intimidating yeah justin timberla's
singing cry me a river on twitter
about where's call of duty going when
you've literally been doing nothing but
stripping xbox gamers of all types of
eyepiece final fantasy dragon quest for
a while yakuza for a while and people
can sit there and say attic it's because
they weren't pursuing these games look i
will agree with you microsoft probably
had a little bit to do with it as not
pursuing these games like really bad
but i don't think it was entirely
microsoft i think there was a lot of
sony that's like over there there's a
lot of relationships going on where
they're just like do you guys really
need access to the market
plus like they're the market leader
yeah the market leader so yeah you're
right about that man
and i think
that's just my biggest issue dirt it's
just like that
people love
microsoft to just bend the knee oh no
it's fine you know if they buy sega yo
if they buy sega next like what what
what's gonna happen then
like are we gonna sit there and say
okay
you bought sega
uh we still think sonic deserves to be
on all platforms like no
the problem is is you guys bit your
horse on someone that can't buy a house
you bite your horse on people that are
door dashing when microsoft is buying
doordash
right like it's just like it is what it
is like if you want
if you want to be able to talk your [ __ ]
back a horse that can that could buy
stuff like look at i'm not even saying
like acting like i'm the one that's over
here buying stuff i don't own a damn
stock in microsoft i don't i don't care
but all i know is
i would never would mike when sony
buy score enix i'm not going to go on
twitter and say they shouldn't have done
it
because i know that they realistically
need to do that are we going to let tim
said by say uh square enix that could be
a huge possibility
that the problem is is there's so much
stuff going on right now
that
sony is not just buying stuff because of
mike it's because of microsoft that
they're like look
there's a handful of companies that can
buy these companies
and they're all constantly keep in mind
amazon is still searching stuff sure
they might not i think amazon's more on
what can we do multimedia now and not
just gaming like you know they
i i was told that the lord of the rings
show
they're putting all their
al
all their money in that one basket
they're like if this show bombs
he's doing well though for him though
that's good so
it seemed like that's more of that
now when it comes to
amazon
keep in mind look some of these games
sure
they're probably not going to sell well
in terms of
finances with a game but amazon's over
there looking at like yo
you know
let's say we do buy activision cost us a
little penny
but we can make like 18 overwatch shows
with that
right they buy you know uh embrace your
group can make can literally probably
develop a network that's dedicated to
gaming lore tv shows and be fine they
got mercenaries uh imagine to destroy
our humans tv show that could work yeah
tomb raider shoot they got two great
there's so much they can do with that
and i think microsoft's still on the
gaming first and then everything after
like what can we get this with gaming
and then after that what can we
leverage those ips to get further on
like they did with minecraft they made
that money right already absolutely
absolutely and you're right about that
yeah
and um
oh i'm sorry you go ahead no no
no so i was about to say
but at the end of the day where where
this all comes down to is
is game pass right microsoft wants game
pass to be the best possible service it
can be
and because they're microsoft because
they have the money to
buy a publisher like activision blizzard
they got the bread
um they want this service to be the best
that it can be now if you think about
how like netflix like some of the things
they did in the past whether it's buying
um you know like making a deal with this
franchise their original uh series their
original movies maybe they might have
one little haywire but then again
netflix is not microsoft
right so microsoft what they're doing
they have to
continue to make game pass the best that
it can be and if you buy the biggest
multi-platform game now first off they
own they already own
one of the top three multi-platform
games
in minecraft now they're about to own
another one
the only other one besides that is gta
and i would say
i would say it's not the same but
overwatch isn't as big as call of duty
but it's got a good impact like call of
duty absolutely right and they're about
to own that people forget
overwatch because it's been so long
since they've done anything recent to
that brand
uh when they drop overwatch too i think
it's october in it next month like
you're gonna see a huge
jump towards overwatch too people love
that game
overwatch is one of the few things
that i've seen come out that's a
multiplayer only and snatched up
game of the year
overwatch is one of the few games
besides something like minecraft that
came in there and be like oh yeah
we doing our own con they do when they
own caught on one video game
chats they're getting kind of crazy um
we got a two dollar super chair nadine
todd
the angry therapist md with the five
dollar super chat jim not worried about
the three years he don't want it in game
it on game pass
yeah that's probably what it is mainly
because even if that game didn't go to
game fast i mean
stayed on their platform
for the most part unless you're like
you're a hardcore like console thing
fan you're not gonna go somewhere else
you're gonna play that on xbox because
it's the best value especially if you
just play call of duty really every year
absolutely ready to play unless you're
like a big playstation fan like you said
there's still millions of people still
on ps4 and xbox one
and
and like when those folks are ready to
upgrade
they're not like us we no i'm a bot i'm
a pony no they're like whatever i want
to do what's best for me what like what
my friends have and people don't realize
you could walk in
to a
into a walmart gamestop target best buy
and you can buy a 300 xbox series s and
walk out of there with call of duty walk
out of the overwatch 2 walk out of there
with minecraft walk out of there with
halo infinite regardless what condition
it is it's still a fun game it's just it
is you know the roadmap should be better
they should have been better prepared
walk out of there with waistline three
walk out like i could keep naming games
ninja blades hellblade walk out of there
with forza there is so much like
if you think about that like
bethesda games that yeah walk out with
fallout 4 fallout 3 fall like new vegas
but like fallout 76 skyrim oblivion
moral field
starfield next year
bro i'm just saying listen but you're
making sense though man and it's like
if okay if you put aside their your xbox
fanboy i'm a gamer first right
and i wish something like xbox game
passes around when i was in my early 20s
when i was broke as hell
are you kidding me [ __ ] i'm still
progressing man still broke this out
give me the super chats
it's just like i think the part that
just gets me annoyed is just the lack of
it's okay if sony does it's not okay
playstation does it like i just like
look
i call both out very equally i i think
that
you know regardless what people call me
you can call me whatever you want you
call me a fanboy this a fanboy that
you can never show me where i like if i
change my opinion on something it's
because i was like someone got me to
change my opinion on something is that
because i flip-flopped is that because
one day i felt like oh you know my views
are lacking dirt time to make some
playstation content uh you know i don't
go with the crowd most of the time i go
against the crowd and i get a lot of
snap for that and
the the part that annoys me
is
you got people
that will
that will say that this is bad but then
they go on twitter and be some of the
most shady people and someone so the
most
you can buy because that's what it is
that
they are changing their opinion to make
more money they're literally
like they're they're make their what's
wrong look for their their opinions not
being bought but it's like
subconsciously being bought because when
you change your your outlook
because you know where the direction of
the wave is going and you do that
intentionally so you can get more money
that is not authentic that is changing
your opinion that that might as well
being bought because you know the super
chat's gonna come through you know you
got probably a hundred more haters in
the chat uh you know how easy it is to
to if i if next week
i just started making anti xbox content
and just
[ __ ] on xbox 24 never talk about
playstation but just
going hard on xbox every day
everyone in this chat most likely
would slowly leave
but i would get the people in here
that will will literally they'll like
the channel because i'm talking mad snap
they'll super chat because they feel
like i'm agreeing with them and i'm
co-signing all their crazy thoughts some
of these people deserves counseling and
let's be real here some of these people
need to be in counseling
it's so easy to do that and you know
that's why i brought dirt on here
because dirt
dirt just does it for fun he's like look
but he he owns everything he plays
everything he never takes none of this
seriously now some of you might take
what he says seriously
definitely but it's never one of those
things where i'm talking to dirt and i'm
like yo
someone someone do a wealth let's check
on him man like what's going on
listen i do prefer xbox genuinely but i
don't hate playstation but at the end of
the day this is
it's all about entertaining
um
like i tell the story on my channel all
the time uh addict
i was just the xbox guy in the chat
watching iron lords watching bgst
watching all of these channels and um
you know just over over so much time
you're like man you know i'm just trying
to be a new fresh voice
it took me a while to get to a thousand
subs but you know i'm growing
but at the end of the day
yes i prefer xbox and i got tired of
playstation fanboys you know the stuff
they did to us last generation like you
know how i always say that beat our
knees in
i just got tired of it and it's time for
us to have some fun but at the same time
i'm not about to lose sleep over this
stuff like
i know
yeah you know like little man baby hey
what's funny you know i might do
i i have stepped away from the smoke
for the most part on twitter i don't
really engage in that too much but you
know occasionally if i know
like you know i guess i get some birdies
telling me when a game is going to be
trash or not and if if it's a
playstation title
i may
or may not set an alarm for 10 minutes
before that that embargo lives i may not
i may do that i may not do that i'm not
going to confirm or deny anything maybe
your boy just sits there in his bed at
night with a little the little blanket
over his head just looking at his phone
just
refreshing and refreshing and refreshing
i might do that and that might be a
little toxic trade of mine if i did that
or if i don't do that let me get these
super chats right i appreciate you guys
it's funny stuff man
what oh yeah okay i think we have rain
blades yeah fight all the super trout
with raven blade go guys in the words of
aaron greenberg
sorry sorry not sorry jim stopped with
the crocodile crying cma can't stop
anything at this court if this goes to
court you're doomed
cma is that the uh people who uh that's
the that's the uk folks oh the uk folks
yeah that um two dollars
lucious augustus jim brian is currently
number 11 trending on twitter oh snap
yeah that's crazy number that that's
like in all of twitter 11. that's crazy
considering
uh from carlos jim ryan is the best
thing to happen to xbox
yeah hey what's up carlos what's up
in a way of the brand because i do feel
like putting games on pc and stuff
devalues the playstation brand i don't
think it devalues uh it devours the
playstation 5 you know the console i
don't think it devours the brand but it
doesn't evaluate the console
you know like tell me
they're not going through what xbox
people went through years ago where
stuff's going to pc
you guys having like the you got
we feel you man
2016 remember xbox guys lost their mind
when xbox announced every xbox first
party games going to pc people say what
i didn't meet like me personally i
didn't care but there was some xbox guys
in the community lost their minds like
this is bs phil spencer what's wrong
with you
oh man imagine that i never forget
imagine the very first game that goes to
uh playstation and pc day and date
we're gonna have my day that day
i might call in sick that day just um
imagine it don't even like dirt it don't
even have to be a trash game like it
would have to be a good game it could be
anything
i'ma latch onto that
like like a tiger trying to feed his
cubs well you know
it is whatever i don't know he can be
sack boy
i don't care like the new sack boy
just give me enough
to go in like what's funny is i troll
people but at least i troll in super
chats i'll go i'll pop in there like a
jabari thing and i'll pop in there i'll
be like how's that call of duty deal
going for you so because because i know
it's jokes that i know it's gonna you
know get get live conversation in the
chat uh you know sometimes people get a
little upset i used to do it to some of
these crazy playstation fanboys and i
started worrying for my health and
well-being
uh some of these guys take a serious
break yeah they're ten dollars super
trapped from shark in a chair okay okay
halo news is killing me man
yeah
halo
you know what i we could talk about that
here in a minute uh raiden blade with
the two dollar super chat dirt al vowel
varya do
how are varado
alvarado hey adam just arrived
appreciate it raven blade uh so you know
we could talk about that later on uh but
you know
i think that's pretty much all we can
really talk about this i think we do
need a little bit more information
before we
okay but man
let phil come out on that stage when
that deal was finalized and say
after three years
this call of duty is gonna be exclusive
to the xbox platform let that happen
and see i'm gonna have a fun day i might
have a fun day
all right so
let's talk about cd projekt red man cd
projekt red we're 47 minutes in doing
the time stands for the time stamp mafia
right now there you go
10 seconds so there you go all right so
now we have a lot of stuff going on
first off did you ever beat
the
uh cyberpunk did you ever beat that no i
dropped it i dropped it like a bad case
i dropped it i picked it back up when
they um upgraded to next generation but
then i put it back down but i'm going
it's a separate game
um i'm going to go back and finish it
because i finished the witcher 3 years
ago because i love love witcher 3 so i'm
going to go back and finish because i
thought the game was pretty solid
the second like you know i went up they
upgraded to
to the uh next gen i thought it was
solid so my question to you is do you
think
with all the damage that they've done to
their brand when they release cyberpunk
uh and i wouldn't even say the way it
was
there's a difference between releasing a
game broken and hiding releasing a game
broken and they were doing a lot of very
shady stuff like silence and dreamcast
guy on twit on twitter and youtube
because uh you know he got a game he
didn't even get a review copy he got he
got the amazon messed up and sent him
his early
so
do you think that
with all that happened the stocks
dropped
all that bad publicity do you think that
they could come back from that
absolutely
i think is
i think the gaming industry well not
just gaming
in life in general for the most part
you you mess up you have an opportunity
to redeem yourself
and they have opportunity to redeem
themselves
if this dlc this expansion that they
have coming out is great people are
going to figure out about it if
the witcher like four or like whatever
they want to make the next with your
people gonna forget all about cyberpunk
trust and believe that's just how it is
if you make some quality stuff
okay that's like with your girlfriend
you piss your girl off
you buy her some
some flowers you buy some candy
you do certain things for her it might
take a minute it depends on how much you
pissed her off but eventually if she if
she loves you enough okay okay you know
let's
let's work this out now don't mess up
again
but at least i gotta gotta get a couple
months before you mess up again like it
gotta be a little bit of a time frame
man if you mess it up week after week
okay i i don't know man i don't know
yeah so
sofa king said he broke embargo
dreamcast guy did he did break embargo
but he wasn't under embargo there's a
difference between you signing a piece
of paper or are you getting a piece of
paper saying that you're embargo and
being under embargo he got the copy he
like he was under pretty much the
embargo of everyone but he wasn't under
like a specific embargo now he shouldn't
have broke it he shouldn't have uh but
because it wasn't his fault he got
access to that game part of me feels
like they should have let him rock
it's like look
but
let me let me say to you this way sofa
king and let me ask you dirt if that was
a lit game and it was actually went the
opposite way that everyone uh that that
it went do you think they would have
silenced them if it was good feedback
probably not yeah i don't think they
would have either
keep in mind he didn't even get a review
copy so that right there is sketchy you
know even if you don't like dreamcast
guy if you don't like the you know the
decisions he makes and some of the
videos he makes he still has a huge
following and if he didn't get a review
code
there's something shady about that in
general
yep
i agree um
but back to what i was saying i just
feel if you do enough
to uh you know like if you look at
playstation 3 xbox one like playstation
3 they messed up at the beginning of
that generation pretty bad
but over the years they were able to you
know fans forgave them for the 600
mishap for some of the things you know
the developers were mad at them like
remember when gabe newell was like the
ps3 is bs
some of the developers was pissed at
sony for the ps3 but they forgave them
the same thing with the xbox one or well
i don't know if that many people forgave
them but
xbox is doing well enough now to see
that people forgave them so as long as
you continue to improve and continue to
do something better to make people
forget about your past mistakes now some
people would never forget
some people you know just will
constantly bring it up like i always
bring up the xbox one generation and all
that stuff but if you do things to make
make everything better
i think people will move on and forget
about it like if halo infinite i know
we'll talk about this later
if they're
if forest drops in november or some
other stuff like couple maps dropped
this year
and whenever they drop like the content
from season three
over time people are going to forgive it
man because the gameplay was always
solid you know what i'm saying like the
game was polished it was just a road map
was the issue i think people will
forgive what happened with 343 not like
some people
but as long as the game is good
okay
and then and then you got to think about
it this way too
gamers were very
what are you doing now
if witcher 4 comes out and it's in this
horrible glitchy
it doesn't have that same um that which
three had they don't fix cyberpunk to a
point where people are okay with it to
my knowledge people are starting to be
okay cyberpunk already absolutely so
they can only go up from here yeah um
the moment they come out of what you're
for and i don't think they're going to
let that launch broken they're going to
take extra time on that
no way it's going to be one of those
things where i i saw i saw me uh i saw a
tick tock and i don't know anyone in the
army i appreciate you for your service
but it saw someone going back to the
armory and he was like turning in his
gun and he sits there and looks at the
armor's like clean this damn thing and
throws it back to him and he comes back
like three hours later and he's like
it's still dirty he throws it back it's
like that's how they gonna do it man
they're gonna they're gonna hire more q
and a's than people actually coding for
the game they're gonna have so many q
a's watching he's like look man this you
push start it takes a half a second
longer to get to the menu at this point
send it back find out why he's doing
that
facts man facts they're going to make
sure that game is as polished as can be
they
that's a wrap i agree i agree bro that's
why i said you know if you
mess up and then you redeem yourself
people will forgive you but if you mess
up and then messed up again
no you're you're in trouble big time
you're in big time trouble
yeah so you know we're gonna move on
with that one because i didn't really
think that was gonna take a whole lot of
our time i just i was very interested
because i see a lot of people say that
there's nothing they could do and i'm
looking at these comments on twitter and
i'm like you clearly haven't been around
that long
you know i will say that they have done
some off-the-wall stuff not gonna excuse
them from that
but gamers are all about
if you give me good content two years
from now
it don't matter what you do now it don't
as long as you can keep the lights on to
give us that content it does not matter
what you do now look at companies
that completely was almost
uh capcom
almost out of business
monster hunter gave them enough money
and they started reinventing games doing
what they needed to now they probably
have some of the most success of all the
publishers right now it does not matter
what you do right now it matters what
you do in the future and as long as you
get someone in there and you can keep
the lights on you can get the the ship
moving in the right direction all these
companies can can turn it around every
single last one of them i don't care who
they are that's why people sit there and
they talking real extra about microsoft
all that generation
justifiable like they needed that talk
they needed that smoke that work but
they took all of that energy you guys
gave them on twitter and they turned
themselves into an ultra instinct goku
and now that you know they
they sitting there just dodging people
you know they they ain't getting hit
sony's trying to hit them in the gut
like eight times in the past year
and microsoft just jumping over them
just jumping over them like jaren trying
to hit goku it's right man
you're right
but always happens
like that if there's a console
generation that doesn't go as well as
that company uh planned it to it that
following generation
they're using on point
right i mean they're using that point
look at this playstation 3 playstation
4. you guys uh the wii u to the uh the
wii u to the sort of the switch
uh and you got the xbox one to the
series x like you know right now we
still a little early in the generation
i'll give you guys that but i do think
we've seen enough to know this is a
different microsoft it's not the same
absolutely easily even i would go far
back to say even the sega saturn to the
dreamcast the dreamcast died prematurely
because the ps2 was a absolute monster
but when you think about the dreamcast
itself all of the mistakes they made
with the saturn the dreamcast was easier
to develop for they had great first
party games and some third party um
exclusives like soul calibur and then
dreamcast was awesome but the ps2 killed
it prematurely but yeah they messed up
with the saturn
they fixed it with the dreamcast but you
know
unfortunately so you know what we're
gonna do i'm going to update the
57 minutes for the for the time stamps
mafia that's updated for you guys yeah
time's still my favorite i'm gonna
literally start calling the timestamp i
like that actually
man they come at me it was funny the
people that would be in the chat was
only a couple it's not like a bunch of
you most of you were pretty chill with
the time stamps it's like look watch the
whole thing or shut up uh but there will
be some that will be in that chat attic
where's the timestamps i ain't watching
this timestamp without timestamp where
are you in the chat now where's my
thanks for the time stamps where is that
at because you were so quick to come at
me over timestamps when they weren't
there where's the ad you listened to
feedback and you did the right thing
where is that i don't see that i feel
away
where is it
we're gonna move on so
we got some place no no we don't we
we're not there yet we got
the ubisoft showcase i think it's
sometime next week i think it's saturday
isn't it oh god it's saturday
i don't know
i don't know if we're going to stream
that
saturday that
saturday like let me double check i
don't want to get you no wrong
information
dawn said
addict sounded like 3 4 3
yo i don't like that comparison
you know what it's fine call me 343
addict it's fine what's the name of this
show the ubisoft showcase ubisoft
something
yeah this saturday
saturday what time uh
3 p.m eastern time
3 p.m eastern time
people in the chat you want iop to react
to that
if you say yes i'ma tell they them that
you said no so just saying
people in the chat put in that put in
that if you want us to react
to the ubisoft showcase
because i'm curious
damn it damn it
why did i even ask them that obviously
they'd be up for free content yeah
that's kind of a stupid question i just
say you go far you're working with me
man you're working with me called
ubisoft forward that's what mark r says
yeah all right
we on will ubisoft now a lot of people
are completely
against ubisoft um they i like ubisoft i
think they make good games i like i do
think that you know maybe they're not
where they used to be
but
who is where they used to be
nintendo yeah i mean even the tempo to a
point like yeah no one is who they used
to be like look
it's a different time it's easy to go
out there and tell a multi-million
dollar company yo that assassin's creed
doing numbers
don't keep doing it
what
you know it's funny you got the same
people telling ubisoft to change stuff
they making the same two different two
to say the same two types of videos on
youtube
make that make sense
usually when you see something that is
successful you try
to dig the hell out of that
you try to replicate that as many times
as you want right
there's a reason angry joe does the
angry reviews
and he has that persona because it's
worked
right
so it's just like you know what first
off we'll do realistic
predictions
what is a realistic prediction dirt that
you see
at the ubisoft forward
showcase um realistic of course they
already mentioned assassin's creed will
be a big focus there which i love
assassin's creed games but a realistic
they're going to show that splinter cell
remake they're developing
the what
they're developing
i think ubisoft is developing i don't
know it's team uh sprinter sale remake
you don't remember hearing about that no
i've heard about it for a while i know
it's in development
i just i don't know
if that's
i don't know if they're ready for that
because i know that they they just
announced it like last year didn't they
yeah
well i didn't say they were gonna like
reveal the release date they might just
show a little bit of it
i mean by being a remake i don't think
it's gonna take like the typical four to
five years
maybe maybe i'm gonna take three yeah
probably take three you know
i think that might be a
a fair realistic expectation i think we
were probably gonna see skullenbones
that's 100
realistic i believe that's totally going
to be there i will say i may or may not
have already played skull bones
oh
really i cannot confirm or deny that
yeah
so you know it's going to be interesting
to see how people react to it i think
it's going to be a good game i do you
think so yeah i know i don't know about
coming out god of war i don't know about
all that right i think uh i think it's
going to find its audience i mean if you
think about it ubisoft's always found
its audience for honored
there's a lot of games that they have
found their audience the division the
rainbow six
the we don't talk about the division
they found their audience and they lost
their
they found it because the first division
i put a lot of time in that game but the
second one i ain't put that much time in
it but like rainbow six is huge
it's probably one of the biggest first
that might be actually one of the
biggest
redemption arcs that's ever happened in
gaming like to be honest it started off
real slow yeah
they thought that it was going to
it was going to um
it was going to flop someone said don't
forget attic to bend the knee to king
for the halo ass whooping
oh but he i beat him once too
so how is that going to work i beat him
see i can't bend the knee to him because
he didn't stand on his on his square
and take that bend the knee
i offered for those who don't know we
did a community night last saturday
sunday
epic fun loved it but so king was
talking that smack like king always
talks so i thought okay king we playing
halo infinite you go over there i'll go
over there and we're going to draft the
people in here
so
let me let me let me tell you dirt we
down by 15.
end of it i ain't go live myself was
thinking this was this is a wrap
like
this this is a wrap so i start i start
to be like i see that i see that that
gauge going up a little bit you know
what i'm saying i'm like oh
we could come back
so we we take the lead
like 15 before the the victory so i'm
sitting there and
i'm doing everything i'm trying i'm
trying to be what the lead is supposed
to be i'm trying to motivate i'm trying
to do what i can i was like you guys got
this
we got this don't
don't give them no ground
and the leader
the king
the moment that victory thing popped up
first thing i hear king is saying
okay i think someone told king sorry
like on his team i didn't hear it
because i was so i was so captivated
just absorbing the wind into my soul
so i think someone said sorry he's like
no we don't tell people sorry and i
think myself now you better tell them
sorry you better tell them sorry man
because you failed them ken you you lost
that game so then we going into the
second one can you like run it back my
dumb ass shouldn't have ran it back okay
second game i should have took that w
and walked out the front door with it
but i did i'm all right king
we'll play this again but i want you to
do a bend the knee on this right
now
if i win
this sunday live
you got to bend the knee
he wouldn't do it
so we playing the next game we bought
maybe 10 15 minutes into it hey that's
probably exaggerating like probably
seven
we losing by 20.
and the king's like oh i'll do the bend
the knee now i'm like oh i sure you
would
yeah apparently king
king downloaded because king didn't
download the game before i don't know
why
um so
he downloads halo because we're waiting
for him and he sends out invites and
it's it's halo 5.
it was a fun time man you guys pulled up
it was a great time like i really
enjoyed that community today i think you
know maybe in the future trying to get
more communities in on it you know try
to do
uh community streams with other podcasts
trying to do like a day that we that we
can get as many people to gather and
play and stuff i think it'll be fun man
i think it'll be fun all right let's go
ahead and move on i
ubisoft you know it is what it is i
think
i think we just need to see more from
ubisoft really uh and i'm i'm curious to
see what they have
i'm not going to be a downer like other
people and say that they're not going to
have anything but at the same time i'm
going to be realistic with their
situation
all right so
let's
let's talk about playstation update so
did you see that did you see the update
playstation got
yeah um i saw austin evans he did
something he broke it down and
yeah i said you know some smaller parts
in there and some other stuff
so it's
like this software update oh the
software i'm sorry my bad um yeah i saw
the 1440p and yeah you said stuff that
xbox one x had yeah i know
so let's let's go over these
chat let's go over these now look look
look at me man we're going to really go
in now shout out to the two dollar super
chat from the angry therapist md this is
317 people watching this hit that like
button that's right you got
317 people watching this hit that like
button we got to get that to like 150 i
think that's fair yeah over 300 people
in here i'm asking for 150 i think we
can do that you guys can do that
all right we're gonna move on though so
you know
i'm looking at this okay let's
let's do this okay
playstation does a a post on september
the 7th at 5 00 a.m they love posting
stuff early ass in the morning here
relatively don't they oh yeah they're
like
new ps5 software features are rolling
out globally today 1440p hdmi video
output
game list
promoting cases
new ps5 xc and now uh enhancements and
social features
so it's cool that they're updating their
stuff and i'm not really
here to talk
snap about them updating i'm not because
i think
it's nice that they are updating their
software and they're giving more
features to their platform
the question i have do you dirty why
does it take so damn long oh that's a
damn good question
i don't think i can answer bro um i i
don't have a clue
i don't have a clue why it's taking them
so long like
hell it took them 10 years to like
figure out how to change their name
didn't they
i don't know man i don't know what's
taking them so long to do basic stuff
that xbox had for years
you know 1440p was on the xbox one x
that came out of 2017. so i'm i'm not
sure why stuff takes them so long
brother
have no idea
it's funny i i just
i just don't understand
why it takes them so long
to run stuff back why is there no
gifting on the on the playstation 5 yeah
that's a that's a good question you know
what you know what it seemed like we
think about like some of the things that
xbox has gifting and some other stuff
you see my xbox for some reason thinks
about the future
you know they think about the next xbox
playstation seem like they're thinking
about the current playstation they don't
think about flying
playstation is like one of those people
that they don't write a grocery list
they just go and grocery and then they
just forget a bunch of stuff later
they're like oh oh we we bought the hot
dogs and what but but we ain't get no
buns
like
did someone get the chili are we eating
hot dogs without chili
exactly
no that's a good analogy that's that's
exactly what they seem like to me
like they know yeah we gonna have this
we gonna have that damn it
we don't have 1440p available on our
console what the hell yeah that's what
it seems like man
i just
to me i can understand like
six months after the ps5 came out why
did it take them so long to have 2
k
video output
and you know it seems like it seems like
the reason that they doing it too is
because they're trying to get into the
monitor space again oh yeah so i feel
like
their platform kind of needs to give you
the option to go 1440p or what's the
point realistic right
so i'm just like
why did it take you this long
we're in 2022 when did the ps5 come out
dirt 2020
two years
yeah
hey hey dirt when did play when did xbox
have 2k output
2017
2017
oh my god
yo
yo tell me how does it feel playstation
fans to get a feature that we had five
years ago
that's crazy
that's crazy
i'm just
that kind of mentality i'm low-key shark
they have ssds in the place oh the ssd
that beautiful lovely ssd
do you remember how some of those guys
were talking to us about the ssd when
they found out that playstation quote
unquote had a better ssd than xbox
series x they ran with it oh they were
talking trash so it's gonna make the
frames better
is it better
sure i mean it it might be better but
does it matter
probably not yeah i ain't seen a damn
thing to show you it's just like you
know i'm sure
you could run ratchet and click on the
ps4 i'm confident you can sure it might
not look as good and it might load a lot
longer
but i'm sure if you wanted to if they
could get the witcher 3 and skyrim to
run on the switch
right ratchet and clank can easily run
on the playstation 4 pro
nice
but so it's the magical ssd the
magical ssd i think
i think that's my biggest point there
it's just like why does it take them so
long to bounce back like when xbox does
something it takes them like
quadruple the amount of time but it
feels like when playstation does
something an xbox needs to recover
they do it relatively fast you know they
they just got a playstation pro
controller what did the playstation pro
what did the xbox controller pro pro
controller i believe 20 was it 2015 or
2016
yoho it was one seven eight years dirt
it was one of those years i'm thinking
it was 2015 they announced the elite
controller i could be wrong so no it was
2015. it's like you have
this
this you know you see the competition
doing this stuff and they're like you
know what
i like that
we're gonna take seven years to make
that
so it took them
the amount of time it takes them to
research and develop
an entire playstation 5
to make their own pro controller
explain that to me please like that's
just my like obviously
i don't know nothing when it comes to
research and development how much time
it goes to but to me when you have some
of the
probably the most talented people in the
world
one would think
you could come out with a controller
and half the time it took me to come out
with the controller
you would think that
i need you to think i need to get
someone oh yeah oh yeah let's talk about
that real quick since we're on it the uh
the elite controller
2.5 that's how i'm calling it okay the
reason that this is lit is because it's
a design labs yeah are you buying one of
these
you know what i
i got that the like halo infinite one so
i'm not
like really in a rush because i'm loving
the halo infinite elite
but i might have to give me a customized
one you know far as colors go because it
looks pretty good man
and and like they're well 130 now
because they don't include all of the
accessories all of the extra stuff so
they're 130.
um so i'm thinking about it man i might
have to give me one
with a green and black
yeah
i think
you know i'm gonna try to come in the
back door and be like microsoft why
don't you send me a review copy
that's a way of doing it yeah i'm gonna
try man i don't know if it's gonna work
you know because
you know
it is what it is uh hopefully i can get
me one uh you know i think we'll i'm
gonna come across one regardless because
i just been wanting the
the ability to do it that's what i want
i i it's nice that you're giving people
the option to change that stuff if they
if they choose to keep in mind you don't
have to do nothing
absolutely man i i mean this is
like just imagine you couldn't get
certain things in certain colors you
know like you get a new car it's only in
black that's it
i mean you'll take it but like damn man
i wish i could have chose my color or
you know so for them to get an option
like you said i think it's cool for them
to get an option
you know it's the option you can use it
or you don't use it but i think it's a
cool just for it to be there
you know now the question is when will
playstation do you think in
2018
okay so it took them seven years to make
the controller
so i'm thinking do we want to do we want
to say it's going to take more years to
to find a way
to customize the controller it's going
to take less years i feel like what
microsoft didn't how long uh the elite
controller came out at 15 we're getting
it now so that's seven years
yeah so sony we look into like 2032 2033
yeah
i feel like it's going to take them a
minute i feel like it's going to take
them a minute let's go on to the to the
to the finale man let's go on to the
finale
playstation
caught slacking man
i don't know i don't know if you saw see
this you were talking about earlier the
austin evans thing
yeah yeah uh so
playstation
has pre pretty much re-infrastructured
the way that the playstation 5 is made
uh every every manufacturer does this
tvs do it everyone does it because they
the goal is
the goal is to make the products as
cheap as possible was still the quality
that the product has so you can make
more money
um for those you know we they did just
increase the price wasn't too long ago i
mean we just we like what a couple weeks
from that
yeah
and now we got austin evans and a couple
other people they picking apart the new
playstation 5 and they're saying that
they have shrunk the heatsink which that
heat seek was huge you could kill a band
with that yeah
uh they shrunk
uh i think it was the fan a little bit
they've done a lot to that platform to
make it cheaper i'm assuming it's going
to be cheaper um austin evans absolutely
why is what they do it right i mean so
you could say be more efficient but it's
to make the yeah make it cheaper to make
yeah you're right so what do you think
sony's like oh good
you know
we finally made stuff cheaper we're we
we're we're doing better with the
inflation
and uh i feel like we're good now nah
sony was like yo
we we
oh it's going to cost less raise the
price raise it up baby raise that price
up sir how much how much you think
they'll pay
like
well i think people in europe will pay
50 100.
no they did at 50. so like to me i've
seen here looking at this
and i'm like why did they raise the
price
if they're making first off they were
making a profit originally
um that was during the pandemic too
wasn't it yeah so that's what they said
one would think that you they might even
be making more money than they were then
i don't know i don't know production
stuff like that
i know the platform i play on they got
bags to fix that
i don't know about sony sony bags look a
little weak no
so i'm sitting here looking at this and
i'm like
microsoft like look it's cost the
business
we got to get
the console to the consumer
and that's just
gonna be have to be that for a while we
use game pass subscription services
selling your games we'll use that to
offset this cost that we're doing now
sonny's like
nah
they paying this i ain't paying this
why you gonna ask me
i gave you the bangers you like that
last of us part two you're paying for it
you're paying the development costs
indirectly you like that you like that
spider-man too we might charge you an
extra 10 for that we don't know what we
doing yet got a two dollar superstar
from divine the stock price is the
reason they charging more okay we're
gonna continue so
what my question to you dirt
is why is no one talking about this i
didn't see it anywhere on twitter ain't
nobody was talking about it i was just
about to say that
before this jim ryan crying news dropped
nobody was talking about this
and i believe this austin ever video was
yesterday or the day before yesterday
nobody was talking about it
we've been around well i'm much older
than you but
every console generation
they do this like you said maybe we
didn't know it back then because the
social media we didn't know it lack of
social media has to say but they do they
do it every generation
the launch model
as
further i mean as um like the counter
generation goes further along
the parts get cheaper then they
eventually do slim models why don't they
do slim models
to make a cheaper console that's like
you said that's the same quality this is
this has been going on for years and
most of the time well actually 10 out of
10 times
the slim models are usually cheaper than
the launch models they're smaller and
they're cheaper
so playstation they're making smaller
parts now the ps5 is still big as hell
it's still the same size on the outside
but
the parts on the inside are smaller so
of course they're probably cheaper
making the ps5 cheaper to manufacture
but yet and still
yeah and still
they raised that price
and like you said addy nobody's talking
about it nobody's saying a damn thing
about it the media nobody i honestly why
it felt like if microsoft raised
the prices on xbox and then
a couple weeks later it was announced
that the series x is being cheaper to
make
i feel like you would see this
everywhere every news media would be
covering this right now you see 15
spaces talking about it you would see
youtube videos popping everywhere it
would be everywhere on tech talk
but i don't see no one talking about
this nobody bro
nobody
i guess they just said who cares i i
don't know why are you talking about it
you know what i think it is
i think that microsoft's a little bit
more accepting when it comes to
criticisms done respectfully
i think people are scared to talk
against sony
because they're scared that they might
pull the curtain back like you ain't
getting nothing from us ever again like
survivor
yeah
i think like likes the wife
they black they blackball them y'all
ain't getting nothing from us
and i think
you see it in different ways like you
saw with what was the thing they just
did um
when they did the last of us part two
the restrictions to those embargoes
was incredibly crazy
it's like one of some of the remake he's
done the remake no the the part two oh
he's on my parts okay yeah that wasn't
that long ago
yeah it was 20 20. yeah those embargoes
was insane
and to me i feel like
you put people in a position
where they feel like they have to play
ball
especially reviewers poor reviewers
because
if you if you max if you
make one of these publishers mad or
these corner console manufacturers
you're done
because now unless you have like a huge
following like you know like acg
dreamcast guy
uh angry joe like you can live with that
because
and if anything they're so big at this
point that i think sony would
be like we can't just cut them off you
know what i'm saying right but we've
seen in a couple of scenarios where
sony's just like we didn't like what you
said
we're not messing with you
and i don't know if this is what's going
on in itself around the industry but i
do feel like
when microsoft gets criticized
a lot of people in the media don't
really talk about it a lot of people
influences don't talk about unless it's
like little channels like us
i i think because we
look would i like to work with sony in
the future yes
am i
am i going to work or so in the future
probably not like
you you got you got the toxic positivity
people on twitter
that uh you know it doesn't matter what
happens in the wrongful way they'll make
some posts it's saying oh this is bad
but then they'll have like a caveat on
top of that why this is good and it's
not directly making it good but it's
something that
appeals to make it good so that's why i
feel like toxic positivity people are
worse than toxic people because
at least toxic people will talk about
something that is generally issues they
just magnetize it to to hell them back
like they they will find the littlest
things and bounce on it but i feel like
people would bring up legit issues
with microsoft with sony with nintendo
and you got these toxic positivity
people on twitter that's that's
rewarding everything they possibly can
to one get their point across and two
make it to where no one's upset with
their comments right and it's just like
look i don't blame the people i don't
blame the influencers i don't blame no
one i call it toxic positivity not
because of the
because the people doing it
but because of the behavior behind it i
call it that because i feel like if you
put someone in a position
where they need the industry to grow
i don't blame them for doing what they
got to do to live i don't
i don't feel like that i feel like we
should come together and stop that
but at the end of what are we going to
do
nothing
you know
there's not a lot you could do in those
kind of scenarios because what people
don't realize is these kind of these
kind of relationships are always like
this
and
i've always felt like
companies should be open to open
criticism well you guys could talk about
about ubisoft all you want
but you could say whatever you want
about their games
and as long as you were respectful
sometimes not respectful i've seen
people say some crazy stuff to ubisoft
and they still get that review code
ubisoft is open for criticism
i don't feel like the same thing with
playstation
you know
playstation won't even let you criticize
your bank account if someone hacks your
stuff because of they security and you
take it to your bank account and say yo
they wouldn't fix it i want you to make
it right place they should be like oh
you snitch they are
getting you for stitching they'll be
like we getting you up out of here we
shutting your whole thing down and i
think that kind of
that kind of mentality is the issue here
microsoft on occasion i've gotten a dm
that's like
yo
i listen to your your words
they don't
they don't belittle me or anything they
say
this is why you're wrong let me explain
it
because i don't know half the stuff i
talk about i'm pure speculation i'm the
speculation king i don't know half that
i don't know how to make a console i
don't know how to make a controller i
don't know anything about network i
don't have to make an xbox i don't want
to make games
but i can talk about them and what i
like about microsoft is they will hit me
up and they'll say this is how the
process works this is what you don't
understand and then i'm educated i'm
good
but i don't think that happens on
playstation what do you think there
no it doesn't um
perfect example
i mentioned survivor the like the
website survivor earlier this year
they gave horizon forbidden west i don't
know maybe a six or something
6.5 or something like that
and word got around when gt7 came out
playstation did not give them a
review code and they previously gave
them a review code for every playstation
exclusive
so when they gave horizon forbidden west
a low score
place i mean like someone like
playstation was like nope
we're done with you guys so there was
consequences
as you said there's there seems to be
consequences with playstation
if they don't like a certain thing and
if if you're ign games spy and all these
other websites it's kind of your bread
and butter and playstation
you know they're they're one of the big
three
so they threaten you for well they might
not openly threaten you but
they see that people walking on
eggshells around like you know like when
it comes to playstation
they're timing they're scared to say
certain things about playstation i
actually feel like
microsoft's too open
for criticism like i feel like when you
get it uh there's a difference between
criticism that's justified and criticism
that you didn't even play the game
right like and i feel like sometimes
microsoft
will take punches from people because
they're big influencers
and they'll come back
professional next time and i get it it's
about the bag it's about selling product
but at the same time it's like if this
dude has done nothing but consistently
show you that he does not mess with your
brand he will do anything he can to
belittle it at any time of the day
sometimes i feel like it's okay just to
cut ties yeah and you know especially
with the xbox one generation they were
given
man i remember i saw someone got a tv uh
not a tv um
a refrigerator you know the mini
refrigerators
they made big refrigerators for certain
influencers yeah i remember that and i
remember they gave it to this this this
chick that opened boxes it wasn't even
she's never done anything with
refrigerators
are you talking to blonde chick
her name she got it is she
it and
she's opening the box and i'm just like
she doesn't even do games
yeah
like i i get that you're trying to show
this product off but you're not even
selling the product
like you made these to give them the
influences you're not even selling these
so why are you doing it
if you've got to follow them because you
got to follow them right you got to use
following me i get it and that that's
like this you know my previous statement
wasn't really directed towards her but
it's just like
you know maybe i'm not
educated enough in marketing to
understand like
the mask i consider that
blind marketing
where
she is probably
even if she got three or four million
followers she's not she's not making
content for games so how many of those
people can you realistically
come back to you you know what i'm
saying like i
when i was when i was working at dish
network
i always heard because i was always in
meetings and stuff and i always heard
stuff when it came to like the super
bowl
the reason people
go to the super bowl is because of that
blind marketing
you you go to the super bowl people
don't really
they don't really advertise to like
the little stuff in tv anymore
like they they they spend a lot of their
their money in marketing i'm gonna try
to reach out to some marketing people i
know to like educate us exactly how
the marketing thing works if that makes
sense
yeah
because i'm curious
on
exactly what goes into marketing i'm
curious to know exactly how it works
well you know what i'm saying is my
quick add before you continue i think
there's a lot of different ways to look
at it
i see what you're saying but at the same
time
a person that's a huge
influencer like she got a huge channel
and one she's a good looking woman too
i can't remember what she looked like
yeah yeah i think you talk about the eye
justine chick she's a good looking one
she get it delivered in her garage yeah
yeah i've heard that i just did because
i saw it also now i watched her channel
that video i never watched her channel
before that but i watched that video it
hasn't been watching their videos since
not once since but
because
blind marketing
yeah that's what it is but because i'm a
gamer i saw she's opening up this xbox
refrigerator let me check it out i
turned to it now
also she's a good-looking woman
now if i was like hey man i if i was
super thirsty i probably would have
subscribed to her hey man she's a
good-looking one-minute but what what
was happening
there are tons of other people say
yo this this xbox freezer is dope man i
wish they had a smaller version oh they
do got a smaller version okay now that
you bring it that way i could understand
from that kind of standpoint someone in
the chat did say they gave it to a
street dog should not make sense it's
just about games
actually snoop dogg has probably done
more for the xbox brand than we have
because superdogs got a massive
following he got no problem going on
twitter and talking that smack
yeah like if if his madden doesn't load
correctly in 15 seconds he is on twitter
saying fix your network microsoft i want
to play madden or 2k or whatever he
plays these days i don't know uh but he
walks out with xbox though he he's xbox
even though he's a casual he only played
like madden and
sports games but he's a casual but he
but he rocks out with xbox though no
doubt he got a two dollar super chat
from raiden blaine sony feeding the
stockholm syndrome just news
talking about the playstation it's like
that that's all i was really wanting to
talk about when it comes to that
is
you know i just don't understand why no
one's talking about it first off and
second off
they were already making money now
they're making more money now they're
increasing the price to make more money
yeah what are we going to start i do
want to ask you dirk because i want to
end this about 15 minutes
when is
it enough to where we can all sit
and
comfortably
except that this isn't playstation 4's
generation
because i i think
i think that is a conversation we need
to start having that this i think we
should have been then start having this
isn't
what this isn't the playstation 4
generation like this is like it's like i
said this is one of those people
it's like a like a mike tyson thing
retire like felt like they they they
left at the top
and you know now now that the
predecessor's coming through then now
they feel like okay let's do this again
and then you knocked out the first round
like
yep
i love this question by the way
so hey let me get this um okay
right before you go dan lazaro the homie
dan lazaro with the two dollars she
games on xbox a lot and is a halo fan
okay well that makes sense see you
educated me dan i didn't know that it's
like i said like i looked at that
no hate on her you know maybe a little
bit of envy there i wanted i wanted a
damn
uh refrigerator but it was just a lot of
like looking at that like yo like
i just didn't see the point
uh long live the black mambo the two
dollar super tree so can't wait to get
king
uh can't wait until uh get king get a
hold of this oh he's gonna wait he's
gonna go crazy king on i don't think you
guys realize
what king about to do sunday
i i yeah man
what's funny is
i'll tell you guys what topic i picked i
don't know if king's picked the topic
yet i picked the topic we're talking
about now so don't don't we we have this
new thing on on iop where every lord
comes
to the podcast with our own topic
because we're passionate we want to talk
about it and
now it's what a kingpin that's that
that's every week we try to figure out
what keen what topic is kings and if
there's two
anti-playstation topics which one of
those is kings because most of the time
it is a king thing uh and i think you
guys are going to enjoy it man i think
you guys are going to jump
tell me what your your logic on this is
man am i tripping am i bugging
well let me say what's up my poster
what's up postman good to see you bro i
gotta post up on here yeah post up the
man bro the post up is the man he's been
bleeding green since the beginning he
never wavered never flip floppy you know
he was out there fighting the ponies
beside the post man
um i'm sorry so so what was we talking
about it's just
what is it
the question right
okay i love this question by the way
i'm passionate about this topic
so i love the question
this is not the ps4 generation we knew
that in september of 2020.
why i'm saying this is because first off
this is not the same xbox from the from
last generation this is the more
aggressive
xbox with microsoft fully behind them
so therefore
the ps5 does not have the same advantage
out the gate
that they have with the uh xbox one a
lot of people that was on xbox 360. i
know some personally in my life
they
moved to the ps4 for whatever reason
price of the xbox one or whatever reason
they moved to the ps4 a lot of people
did that
now this time we're not really seeing
people move to the ps5 we're seeing some
people move to back to the xbox we're
seeing some people stable playstation we
see and some people stay with xbox but
playstation doesn't have that advantage
of
of a wounded xbox going into this new
generation two
xboxes
just spending money like crazy we
already know what's going on
and three some of the decisions
playstation has made
from 70 games and me personally i don't
have a problem with seven dollar games
but some people do have a problem with
it a 10 upgrade fee
when your biggest competitor doesn't
have that upgrade free fee for these
games
you look kind of foolish
like why are your games getting this
damn upgrade fee
um three i i believe playstation is
admitting
that they were behind in certain aspects
what i mean is
games as a service multiplayer games
i always say this addict the ps4
generation in my opinion while it was a
great generation for sony
great games
some things about that generation is
coming back to bite them in the butt
what i mean is games after service
multiplayer games
last generation the industry before our
very eyes was changing we was noticing
these they didn't change with it they
didn't change with it they said no we're
going to continue to do these 200
million dollars single-player games why
they were great games don't get me wrong
but you play them you beat them
that's it then they see a free-to-play
game like fortnite making
tons of money
they see a game of
pub g making tons of money war zone
making tons of money when you have to
rely when you're on an envy towards pub
g you need to change how you're doing
things exactly
but the thing is when you have to rely
on a third-party game
to be your best-selling most profitable
game every year
that's where the issue comes into play
now that third that like said
third-party game
is about to get picked up by your
biggest competitor now
there we go man shout out to bg i i love
you know regardless how people feel
about bg
bg he's been so extra over this call of
duty because bg's always been like look
sony needs to do better multiplayer he's
been doing saying that for years yeah
and everyone keeps saying well
you know their mindset is they don't
need to work on multiplayer they'll let
everyone else do the multiplayer and
they'll just do the single player i
remember that
they went when they announced their
probably call of duty
bg quality and he's like so what about
that
that that multiplied doing doing the
multiplayer what's going on there guys
like
and he's right because if they would
have took the initiative to make sure
that they had a valuable service at that
time
and they would have built up some brands
obviously you're not going to have hits
every time no of course they would have
built up a brand
they would have something to answer to
this
now they're in a situation to where
they might have to actually
work with microsoft and maybe give up
things that they were going to do in the
future
to make sure playstation stays on for
that duration that three years
obviously i don't know if they did
anything like that but for all we know
sony was lining up something that was
gonna be
devastating to to microsoft and help
them a lot and then play microsoft just
pop centers like
yeah we know about that i know you
didn't think we know about that but we
know about that
how
you just look at jim jim how how
important is call of duty staying on
your platform how important let's be
realistic here you know you got that
time exclusive you about to do jim
how how much do you want it
and james sitting there looking to film
like
i i i liked it but you know
just look at him like how much you like
call of duty i like call of duty
i like call of duty 2 phil
so
can you know i feel like there's a way
that there's a world
where we keep call of duty on the
playstation platform
but you don't bring any of that over
there to us like we don't like that we
don't like that gem we we we like
fairness if we're letting stuff stay on
your platform i think it would be safe
to say square enix games could come to
xbox platform what do you think about
that jim
i guess phil looks
it's long you'll keep you keep call of
duty on our platform though right we'll
do it for three years three years i
think it's pretty good
pretty good jim i think three years
that's broad adequate i got a terrible
that's inadequate feel man you know what
the thing is so funny because
back to your initial question
a 2020 addict i know you noticed it i
might have answered this before i know
you noticed the community
the influx of xbox guys just came out of
nowhere in 2020 there were some guys
that told me they started they found my
channel in 2020 while in quarantine
so there was this whole
crew
new xbox guys that came in this talking
trash
and i was like well this is definitely
different from last generation last
generation it just seemed like it was uh
it was five
thousand playstation guys and 100 xbox
guys just i seen last generation because
you know playstation 4 was so popular
but
yeah i mean you have to be a fool not to
see the xbox has a momentum at it xbox
ain't had no damn first party games all
year
oh yeah
oh yeah and the steel playstation get
destroyed the last few months man and
what's funny is like
sure i will say that you know they
haven't won npd in a couple months
they've always lost by like a little bit
but i think it's safe to say derp coming
from xbox one generation
there should be no 20 000 difference
right they should be two to three to one
i thought i thought
i thought the bangers would carry them
this whole way
like it's almost like it's a new
generation dirt
it's it's like playstation
they really thought people was gonna go
out there and you know what i like my
playstation five uh i know this is a
hundred dollars more expensive
and and in some of the words 50 dollars
more expensive
i'm just i'm going to buy it i'm going
to be bobby boucher because it sounds
like bobby it's better to say my brother
i'm gonna buy it
i don't care if it's cheaper oh do you
what do you play i just play bad that's
all bad
okay i think this xbox series like bad
and better xbox series x it's it's it
does pretty good
but how much is it it's three hundred
dollars well why is it why is the place
that's five
whoa well uh bobby it's it's 500 because
that's that's what the playstation 5
retails mama's saying that's fine mama
said mama
said that's good
i can i can
so what what
i can i could buy a game i could buy
call of duty well well actually bobby
call of duty comes
with with the xbox series that's in
gameplay really
would be proud
hey you know it's a funny little addict
this christmas this holiday man i know
sony has got a war
listen bro
was that agc to say earlier on twitter
that he heard a rumor by xbox might do a
price rock this holiday
listen man that's my series is going to
be 250 bro i don't give a damn what
banger quote unquote playstation has
the xbox series as a move units i don't
give a damn what game playstation has
you know what's funny
is the fact that even we all know that
even if if god of war comes out and it's
selling and not as great as they even
anticipated
they're gonna hit the red button dirt
they're gonna they're gonna just bundle
that
oh you know play god of war ain't
selling that well and jim ryan is like
bundle it okay we're good 500 no 550
they paying for that
they pay for it
so we are giving them the 20 discount oh
that's right we did do the price
increase 5.70
[Music]
don't love it trust me they're gonna
love it
so let me ask you a real quick question
you know this is completely off topic
but we've been off topic for a minute
what's your metacritic score prediction
for god of war because i'm curious
i don't think we're going to see much
more than we've seen already like
yeah yeah yeah
so put in the chat with the chats
metacritic score we'll give you a three
point
difference like you could have like 87
to 91. three points
i think 91 actually 91.
so you think it's could still go itself
said 13. you still think it's gonna it's
gonna hit over the 90s
i think so uh i think playstation hasn't
hit over 90s in a while
i think
they're gonna get a 90 yeah
yo why isn't that what's that sucker you
know what kid smooth make a bet with me
that that guy i will bet you kid smooth
that god of war
will
will get an 89 and kiss me bet with me
that it gets a 95. let's get that in the
89.
no
every kid's mood does it's the opposite
all right right i mean
so kids move bets since then over a 90
it's going to be under a 90. i believe
in the power of kid smooth okay like and
in the words of of of bg
he's he's a weapon of mass destruction
right now like
if you want to win wars
just
just have smooth bet that you're gonna
lose that war
that's funny two dollars
from the angry therapists
uh 89 for that dlc i don't think it's
dlc look like king might joke around
about that i think it's going to be a
very look if you want to get technical
almost every sequel to a lot of games
looks like dlc because for the most part
they reuse assets
they they do a lot of stuff to save
costs because that's the reason most the
time that sequel doesn't take five extra
years to make it takes like three
because they want that out as fast as
possible and i think we're going to see
a good game man i i think i think god of
war is going to hit i think maybe a 91
90. i i i don't know why for some reason
everything in me doesn't think it's
going to get
past the 91
i don't know i hope it does cause
like dirt it's been it's been dry out
here like
i i'm struggling i'm struggling to stay
awake i'm falling asleep right now on
the podcast like i'm struggling man i
need i need good games and i'm not
saying there hasn't been good games but
you know every year there's like that
that one killer ip i don't feel like
we've gotten that in a while
yeah no elder ring i would say elder
rings one
yeah elder rain
there's only usually one lots of elden
rings that game and like it's like the
gaming gods have just ascended the
energy from from god of war the moment
saudi's like it's coming out in 2022.
they're like we like elder ring more
we're just gonna give them all the
energy like
two dollar super chat for pixel bit g
just not half of the stage could be from
2018
stages oh so he's saying they could
reuse stage they probably will or
they'll take a stage and put snow on it
and just
redirect some of like the assets on it
listen
instead of instead of the rock being
over here it's going to be over here
yeah they go
when they grab the cursor and move the
rock from the left to the right side and
i could just hear i can hear the
reviewers right now you know i really
love the new stages like
yeah hey man one quick question before
we go
it's
september 7th
um didn't people say there was going to
be a playstation showcase on september
8th
september 9th
in that case it's not happening but
you're trying to be was you trying to be
are you trying to try to throw some
shade trying no i just know people in
the chat was curious at it they just
wanted to know uh you know some people
were saying it's guaranteed to happen
september 8th which is tomorrow
um i don't see it happening on friday
either
maybe monday uh maybe they announce it
tomorrow monday at this point let's just
say it's happening next year
we keep pushing the post
hey
let me tell you something
if playstation doesn't have a showcase
issue
you talking about talking some serious
trash bro
so okay okay okay let me get these super
chats we're gonna talk about that
briefly all right so uh we got a five
dollar strip shirt from long live the
black mope i love that name i don't know
what model first comes out a week before
god of war and is looking like the best
card in years watch god of war be low uh
below expectations and everything they
know will crumble yo i'm gonna re-road
with you if gargoyle comes out and it's
like a
a low 80s i'm roasting people
like i'm i'm i'm roasting people like
you know that scene in fallout new vegas
where you're walking and everyone is
like been crucified and stuff i'm
roasting people to that degree
everybody's getting it
it's god of war isn't to where people
look i'm still playing i'm gonna still
enjoy it because i love god
but if it's not how some of the people
be trying to hype this god of war up for
years people been hyping this game up
like right now i you know as long as it
comes out this year can't get delayed
though it cannot get delayed because i
cannot do another bend the knee will
keep it's got to come out this year but
if that
game does not come out and it hits the
way it is i'm roasting people because
they've been roasting me
but as long as they don't get delayed
all right all right let's talk about
that real quick let me actually make a
another
uh you you just brought up a new topic
man oh man my bad man playstation
the timestamp mafia i could just leave
this out here but i'm not m.i.a
for 2022
question mark we are at
one hour and 51 minutes timestamp mafia
so you got that one hour and 51 minutes
all right so
i guess my question to you would be
15 seconds i'll put 15 seconds
it's
where do you think it's going to come if
it does come this year
if it does come to you i'm thinking
later this month
um because if it was going to be the
12th they would have probably announced
it this week i i i mean we keep getting
like a little bit of i haven't seen no
one worth anything
leak anything for this thing yet
yeah
it's always been like
i know a guy that knows a guy that knows
a guy that knows
it's never like anyone worth anything
like people in the chat i haven't really
been keeping up with uh twitter a whole
lot like put in the chat if there is
people that's saying stuff like this
because i'm curious
the only thing i saw
the snitch like you know the snitch
right he's pretty pretty accurate
he said tinder right like the dayton
website tinder so people's like what and
um i forgot who said they would say well
tinder
was
uh developed or not developed what's
wrong with it for
it started on september 12th
so that's why some people's running away
is he saying the playstation showcase is
september 12th
that's all he said now he didn't say
anything about playstation he just said
tinder so so that's what some people
were running with now the 12th is monday
if they don't announce it tomorrow or
friday it's not gonna have they ever
done one on a monday though
not that i remember i remember maybe
they had one no they're always on
thursdays they're always on thursdays so
that means
it would have to be neither tomorrow the
15th to 22nd or the 29th of this year
um is there any holidays this year uh on
those days
i don't in september no
so it could be any of those days now i
think this this week's crossed out it's
crossed out yeah the i think this week
is definitely crossed out
i feel like next week's probably crossed
out too because we would be hearing some
form of leaks by now
or like you would
have they ever announced
a showcase
now i do remember them announcing like a
state of play like a couple days before
but a showcase they usually give us at
least a week
so i would say next week's probably out
too
like maybe i mean maybe maybe maybe
we'll see if it doesn't get in by the
end of the week next week's probably not
happening either
because it's like i said normally we get
semi-leaks
then we get an announcement then like a
week later we get the actual event yeah
yeah so we haven't heard nothing it's
been dropping anything bro no
playstation news
yeah i feel bad for playstation shout
outs probably why i talk about xbox so
much but anyway
um you know
okay let let's say that it doesn't
happen
let's say that we
september comes and goes no event and i
i want to point out that i believe
they're going to have an event
a good
good point tokyo game shows next week
too
so i don't think they're going to want
to do anything next week because the
tokyo game show
so it had to be the week after but dude
at that point is it kind of i yo
yo
i'm starting to think they might not be
here this year i forgot about tokyo game
shows names and xbox is that tokyo game
show and playstation is not
and you look i also like live supremacy
i forget that the marvel show is friday
wow
you'll be saw for saturday shouldn't
they be somewhere around here
yo remember remember a couple years ago
they said there could be at thousands of
events or something like that
we're gonna be a hundreds of events
after the council e3 we're gonna be 100
self-evidence
where
to be honest it was a pandemic so
probably you know that that that
probably no that was 2019 when they did
that brother they counseled that in 2019
before the family
hundreds of events
hundreds
okay but that went down it doesn't that
was that like i don't even think it was
thousands man i don't remember they
weren't at pax that year
yeah we gonna be wait
they they're doing like those comedy
shows they have like a place they should
boot in the back
they sell them like shirts and like
coffee mugs oh man now i remember 2020
they actually had
two shows in 2020 during the height of
the pandemic
i thought both shows was decent but now
the september show i thought was really
good but
whatever they showed didn't matter
because when they announced that horizon
forbidden west the spider-man
miles morales and all that stuff would
be on the ps4 that's the only thing
people talked about jim ryan lied to us
he said we believe in generations but i
remember they had two shows in 2020 they
had one last year of course they always
had state of plays here and there but
now both of those not in 2020 and 2021
those shows are in september
so this is getting interesting
you have just
like i ain't gonna lie man you you have
just
i didn't think about that like
i didn't think about
especially now since they're talking
about
the
you know the tokyo game show
that really does get a question when
they're doing it
like are they willing to go after tokyo
game show like a week after the kill
game show if not we talk about two weeks
because at that point we're talking
about the end of september and about the
end of september we're in october
what damn that's something think about
me
oh so let me ask you a question dirk
hypothetically we in the world of the
united world you know
attic world i don't know if you know
this but i'm the governor of the active
world okay
everything in my reign
is controlled by me so i'm saying in the
attic world playstation doesn't have a
show
this year what what is your thought
process in the attic world they don't
have a show this year
if playstation doesn't have a show do
you know what that means to me
personally what does that mean to you
person
i think that means
they don't have enough to show
i think that means
spider-man 2 is probably the next
big or like you know besides god of war
of course the next big game that comes
out first party
and i don't think anything else is ready
if you think about gorilla they just
drop
horizon polyphony jet drop gt7
naughty dog already said they're
developing the multiplayer game and they
won't show that until next year
god awards dropping in november
sucker punch they're working on goes to
sushima too that's not ready yet
um
all of those studios they bought
this year last year they're working
they're not ready to show anything
like haven they're not ready to show
anything so
dirt dirt dirt
tell me
what's twitty going to look like if they
announce the show next week and it's
nothing but the free to play games and
vr stuff
you know the answer to this question
that i got to hear it though man i might
not know we might not be thinking about
the same thing so you're asking me if
playstation they have a show but they
only show what you say they only show
the the 10
games as a service they have development
and some of them not all of them and
they show vr titles
because they've showed vr at these
events before so that they definitely
have
um all i know is that
xbox pro xbox channels that talk trash
like mine
we are going to have a field day
on twitter
on social media i'm gonna go live my boy
sean gonna go live we're gonna have a
field day
if something likes that happened because
i'm gonna tell you right now
all my hate
well i don't hate anybody
but all of this uh this built up
resentment from before playstation
fanboys was created
was created last generation and it's
just like a big ball of fire
if that happens
you know i'm at to like jump up and like
imagine like me going from like like i'm
batman like going from rooftop to
rooftop and then i just hit like a
button and there's just a big ass dirt
sign in this in the sky i'm not the
batman yo ass like it's gonna be like an
emergency attic show it's like i just
hit it and like bing and it's just like
a giant
sign that's in that's you know i don't
even think i want it in the air because
i feel like i feel like that's
disrespectful to playstation at that
point i want like in the dirt that's
where it is it's in the dirt i'm
summoning dirt from the dirt like
it's like a giant symbol
hey now now the black john has something
if they do have a show
excuse me
they'll focus on final fantasy for
spoken
but you know stuff that's not first
party they might focus on some
third-party stuff because i do believe
they're going to have a show this year i
think they have to
i think they have to
and they're gonna have one they're gonna
source the vr stuff they're gonna show
you know the final fantasy stuff
like i said for spoken i'm trying to
think of what else they have um i don't
know man maybe this is some other
third-party games they haven't announced
so i do believe they're gonna have a
show but i think it might be a little
light on first party stuff besides god
of war and probably spider-man too
so i had a quick question do you think
that if they do have a
if they do do that do you think it's
gonna
what do you think
the outreach would be like because i
feel like if microsoft went out there
and they just showed
second party stuff people would be a
little upset maybe because they just
showed so much first party stuff
like you know spider-man wolverine
yeah i'm
a god of war that's about all it's all i
can think about right now uh but do you
think that they would be okay with that
or do you think that it would be one of
those things where people like that's
cool that i get to play that playstation
but what's your people doing like yeah i
think some people will ask that question
like okay
we no no i think if that happened i
think the show would get
a negative rating even from like besides
the extreme pony negative radius
see like they'll be like look man we've
seen final fantasy 16 we've seen for
spokane it's cool
spoken more
um
it'll be cool to see some spider-man 2
because the soundtrack is gameplay good
developers so i am expecting that game
to look great
but i think if they don't show anything
new and big first party
people are going to be disappointed like
come on playstation what what what's
going on we know about spiderman we know
about
you know force before spoken
at first spoken
for spock is definitely i'm not gonna
say the game looks horrible horrible i
do think that
it doesn't look appealing to me
um
i am a huge final fantasy
fan i didn't i think 15 was a good game
it wasn't i think
i was so bad with 12
i mean 13 i felt like 15 was a step in
the right direction but i don't think
because these are the developers that
are making for spoken as those people
okay
it just doesn't look appealing like
every time i see it like
they show me oh
she's in this world
but i just i don't see nothing with this
world
like
there's no appealing stuff to it like i
don't feel like
there's no energy in the in the
storytelling
there's some cringy
some cringy dialogue too
and it's just like you know
especially
the dialogue too
it's just like
i don't
get why they continue that dialogue you
know what i'm saying like yeah it might
have worked with the kingdom hearts and
the older final fantasies but it's like
can we please get some serious dialogue
like this isn't supposed to be not like
a serious game it's supposed to be a
serious game
why do we have such cringy dialogue
i don't know i do
what what what do you think what do you
think first spoke it's going to matter
critics score
80. what we've seen so far 82.
from what we've seen so far about 81 80
to 82 and yeah
if this gets below below 70 wait what
are you doing
you know what i'm doing
baby
talking that
look i'm curious chat
put in that put in that chat what you
think it's gonna get
if anyone posts above an 80 you're
getting blocked
70 69 i think i think it's going to get
above a 69
77. i think
i think if if this game got in the 70s
wouldn't surprise me
it wouldn't surprise me one bit
it wouldn't surprise me but you know
we're gonna go ahead and uh start to
start to
wrap this up man i appreciate ever
coming through man you know thank you
man you know i was having fun bro we are
let me let me let me check the mafia
police okay we're at two hours
and five minutes
uh you know i try to keep these below
two hours most of the time i do a good
job about it uh but this
well you know what it was i blame you i
blame you that was my fault we was about
to end this show and then you asked me
what happens if playstation didn't show
up this year i didn't actually really
answer that yeah just to clarify
i don't think it looks bad for sony but
i do think that's one of those things
where it's like it's not a good look
if you're not there in any way shape or
form and people consistently say well
they have nothing to show just like you
said that is true they probably in the
show
but they did announce games like eight
years before they came out too
yeah so it's just like at that point do
they have nothing to show or they just
not wanting to show it i don't know it's
that's a good question
if they don't
honestly if they don't have a show like
you said i don't think it's going to
really hurt them maybe you will but
maybe not that much but like you know
that jail for that nba player nick young
with the question marks pop up
like you know
like if they don't have a show that's me
like what
what's going on sonny because it doesn't
make sense that i think that's the
biggest thing it doesn't make sense does
it like and think about it we're a few
months away from microsoft like
microsoft had there's a while ago
like june yeah june
august
i know the video game awards comes up
and you know microsoft always shows
something there but i don't know man um
but see there's a thing that okay i know
we're going to end but this is the one
thing i want to say before we go
even during a year like 2017 when xbox
had no games they still had a show
2018 they had no games they still had a
show
so
it makes you question like okay
playstation do you care enough but i
think they'll have a show though but as
of right now i'm talking trash because
they haven't announced the show but i do
think they will have a show this year
man i don't know yeah and we're gonna we
we're gonna have a good time if they
don't but anyway man tell the people
where they can find you at man what
what's what's going on
hey uh check out my channel let me put
my channel link in the uh
i mean the spam
the chat uh they're greatly you know i
i'm a pro xbox channel that talks a lot
of trash
about playstation fanboys but i also
talk gaming news that's what i do
just like any other channel but you know
i just try to be entertaining so stop by
check it out my podcast is on monday
evenings
who is it spamming spam
6 30 p.m eastern time called wbg xbox
podcast like you know check it out guys
i'm on twitter at griggity
g-r-i-g-g-i-t-y well you guys see it up
there my name oh no you don't see it i
see it you don't see it so that's about
it guys
thanks for having me again addict yeah
i'm addict uh obviously going to be at
the iop this this sunday at 1 pm i'm
sure it's going to be a very interesting
show appreciate if we're coming through
we had about 340 people somewhere around
there might have been a little less
little boring i don't know i don't keep
track appreciate every couple three man
every week you guys pull up and we
always try to deliver sometimes we don't
deliver you know so sometimes uh we like
to take a little break and just
cruise good job joking man we come in
here every day with 100 energy i come in
here every day is goku ultra instinct
all right but i appreciate ever coming
through i'm gonna direct you guys to
fame over there go in there type in his
chat when you go over there say addict
from the addict and dirt sent you from
addict uh addict show i appreciate ever
coming through you guys have been been
terrific man and until next week this is
addict and dirt and we